hidden we finish the settings don't
check it out oh great wait let's put all
this stuff right here I'm glad you asked
all this stuff will help me demonstrate
the power of implicit intents leveraging
other apps to get functionality for your
app for free for example why would you
write a barcode scanning app when you
can just launch an intent to do it for
you or a camera app when you can just
launch an intent to fire a photo and of
course it would make no sense to write a
phone app just to dial a phone number
you would just call the intent hey I
need that in other words don't reinvent
the wheel lazy programmers make fewer
mistakes now let's go implement an
implicit intent made up Dan's being
implicit again